This video introduces Sikuli,
an interactive technique
that uses screenshots
to search and automate
graphical user interfaces.
Sikuli Search allows users to
search a documentation database
using screenshots of interface
elements, like this dialog box.
User draws a rectangle
around the dialog box
to capture it's screenshot
and submit it to Sikuli.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sikuli currently
searches a database
of more than 50,000 screenshots
from over 100 computer books.
It then returns a list of pages
containing the screenshots
of the same dialog box.
User can browse
and select a page
to read the details
about this dialog box.
Sikuli Script allows users
to write simple scripts
to automate GUI
interaction by screenshots.
Consider this bus
tracking interface.
With Sikuli Script, a user can
draw a rectangle around the bus
symbol to take it screenshot
and select a neighborhood
on the map to watch
for the bus arrival,
also by taking a screenshot.
After taking the
screenshots, the user
can use them directly in
a statement asking Sikuli
to find the
neighborhood on the map,
look inside, and
find the bus symbol.
If such a symbol is
found, a pop-up window
can be displayed to notify
the user the bus has arrived.
Sikuli Script supports
many visual commands.
It can be used to click
on visual targets,
to drag a visual target onto
another visual target, to type
a string in a visual target,
in this case, the Google Search
box in the web browser.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With Sikuli, what you
see is what you search
and what you see
is what you script.